and our returning champion a bartender
from new york new york austin rogers you
did have these moves what was that all
about you know what it's like when
you're just staring at it and they're
like oh no we're rolling no no no not
sorry sorry reset and they're like
a bartender from new york who's in it
and you're just like looking at the red
line you're like
i don't know what to do with my hands
i'm just like my
balloon animal pop
did alex like it yeah
eventually it took him a while you guys
can play however you want new york
bartender austin rogers has been hosting
pub quiz nights for 15 years before
trivia became a booming industry and
before his 12-game winning streak on
jeopardy made him a viral sensation you
went on to win
all these matches of jeopardy you're
still a bartender from new york and we
are at said bar and i am still here on
the weekends because
one i love it and two uh we're still in
new york so four hundred eleven thousand
dollars everyone's like why didn't you
buy a house i'm like where i used to
work corporate i used to wear a suit and
tie never again am i going back there
his love of trivia can be traced back to
his childhood in westchester new york
where he grew up a self-declared geek we
were the dorky kids my clique was the
geekdom so
incumbent upon that growing up in the
80s and 90s is you know the getting
bullied and stuff like that hopefully
kids these days are having a better
chance of it with more inclusionary just
society and the fact that
knowing stuff and being a dork is is
pretty cool right now you know did your
knowledge
come from
[Music]
books did it come from
absorbing pop culture i was always an
avid reader memorizing dinosaurs and
world war ii airplanes and i think that
just that love of knowledge will
translate to
knowing stuff about buzzfeed and the
kardashians just because if you can
remember chopin and schumann you can
also remember kim and kanye right
next up name this five-letter furry
friend rogers is well-rounded thirst for
knowledge drove him to recognize
patterns in jeopardy questions they'll
have these little weasel words these
little things that jeopardy uses again
and again and again that's this little
auditory pavlovian cue like all you
could see is american artist and iowa
and you go it's grant wood the guy with
the pitchfork american gothic that's all
you need to know american artist iowa
because there's no other place where
those two things are going to align
that is in canonical pop culture so
the question and how you write it how
you ask it or phrase it is as important
as the answer
yes memorization isn't trivia it's also
how you grab what is else is out there
we put his strategy to the test in our
own trivia game match-up falling out of
favor in the 1860s this drink got its
name in the 1880s after coming back into
style so one thing was in the past
other things in the future
[Laughter]
what do you call something in the past
you call it
i see what you're trying to do here okay
there's a time frame difference here
1880s and 1860s is irrelevant the fact
is there's a gap in time between these
two drinks
maybe because the drink was
old-fashioned
here's the next one zoom trivia came
into fashion during the pandemic when
people were locked down rogers expanded
his community online and realized how
meaningful the movement can be this
young man types and says the name i'm
using on my screen name i just got to
tell you this really means a lot to me
i just transitioned and i haven't ever
been called my new name and this was the
first place where people are saying hey
bo great to see you and i hadn't heard
my new name yet because i've been under
lockdown and bo still plays my trivia on
wednesdays and like
gut punch this little teeny dumb little
trivia community that i created under
lockdown had this young man
told for the first time his new chosen
name
and been embraced like people like bose
here this is so exciting i am doing this
for people because there were the
bullied and the geeks and the yada yada
yada and it's it's
cool during the height of the pandemic
rogers says his trivia community raised
more than 65 000 to help out-of-work
bartenders the ultimate book of pub
trivia by the smartest guy in the bar is
on sale wherever you get your books so
you know the the way you were asking me
nate about the the clues that are within
the question so a a bad question would
be who was the name the original name of
the count of monte cristo
anybody
but if i say to you this way he called
himself the count of monte cristo and
alexander dumas classic novel in 1844
but his family knew him as
i would also not know
edmonds is the character in the account
of monte cristo but you see i gave you
some clues there in asking you a random
trivia question uh manford man did
blinded by the light who wrote the song
that's not a trivia question whenever we
play trivial pursuit in my house uh my
mom always says florida forever
they were like what country has the
world's largest lakers like florida
eventually should get it right get it
right yeah exactly this was a
fascinating story because he just has a
very unique perspective on trivia and
the things that we all absorb especially
as children the books that we read the
movies that we watch the music that we
listen to that's how he was able in that
community he created it's about
friendship and community and the best
part of a bar that's right
right about that great story that is
true